huge controversy over the right to
self-defense as ordinary citizens
grapple with the liberal city crime wave
the new york post obtaining video of a
violent ex-con attacking a hard-working
store clerk here in new york city but
the clerk fought back and stabbed his
attacker to death
now 61-year-old jose alba finds himself
behind bars at the notorious rikers
island jail
radical d.a alvin bragg slapping him
with a murder charge and setting his
bail at an eye-popping quarter of a
million dollars
thankfully it got reduced to 50 000 and
he should be out soon keep in mind this
is the same d.a who basically got rid of
cash bail and lets criminals roam free
and the situation is sparking outrage
with the new york post summing it up
this way with this headline self-defense
isn't a crime
it's time for manhattan d.a to ditch
her alvin bragg and the city's mayor
eric adams stopping by the store and
standing up for the clerk
now it's time for the district
attorney's office to make to do an
investigation and a grand jury
to
go through the proceedings
but
i'm just a big believer that innocent
new yorkers
who are doing their job working it's
obvious this gentleman was here
broken provided for his family
judge this reminds me of the written
house situation it's all on video oh
yeah you see the video but this is even
more clear-cut yet they still hit him
with a murder charge look this case is a
microcosm of what's going on in america
today the victim is seen as someone who
should be ignored and the criminal is
the one who's being protected in this
situation what you have is a guy who
doesn't have a criminal record who's
worked his whole life who goes to work
at noontime and then comes home at like
three in the morning or some crazy time
and you've got a dirt bag career
criminal two prison stints eight at
least felony arrests okay he jumps over
the counter fighting words throws a
bodega owner into a chair pushes him
curses at him yells at a customer then
pulls him out of the chair and while
he's cursing at him and then the bodega
owner in self-defense takes a knife out
stabs him kills him that's called
justification in new york state if you
were faced with deadly physical force
and you were reasonable in your belief
that you were going to be harmed based
upon these circumstances then you have
the right to defend yourself but you're
right it is a written house case and the
problem with this in new york is
everybody walks free you use a gun in
new york you get to walk free this guy
alvin bragg he doesn't deserve the title
district attorney and i got to tell you
i don't have a lot of faith in eric
adams i mean he's over here saying you
know what
i'm not allowed to give commands to a
local prosecutor baloney you were hired
because you're a cop who's anti-crime
they're taking the side of the criminal
and not the victim this is the victim
who's being charged with murder now has
to go through the justice system and the
grand jury to prove that he was indeed a
victim and it's all on tape do you buy
that the mayor can't say anything about
a district attorney i mean people talk
about da's all the time i would have
said something i don't think this is the
ridden house case at all but i agree
with everything's been said that that
guy should be let out of jail
uh the mayor should say to alvin bragg
this is wrong i don't know what choice
looking at this video that this
gentleman had
i would have done the same thing and i
think any red-blooded american any
father any uncle any grandfather would
have done the same thing as well it's
unfortunate it had to come to this
conclusion but that gentleman being
pushed right there he had nothing to do
with instigating this situation it all
came upon him and he responded like i
think anybody else would have dana
perino you think this is going to have a
chilling effect on i mean anybody any
store owner well i well certainly but i
don't know if you saw that the bodega
owners they have an organization an
association they called guess who today
for help
the nra oh so
well done everybody here in new york
city you think you hate guns so much but
now you have people who are actually
trying to run businesses and they have
to go to the nra for help because you
won't help them you won't allow them to
protect themselves and let's remember
this all started because this guy
al the other guy the one who died
his girlfriend had come to the store and
tried to buy a bag of potato chips and
her debit card doesn't work now she
pulled a knife
and then she left yeah and she told the
boyfriend what happened and that's when
he comes back so i also think that when
as bragg is doing his investigation sort
of speed that up because when he comes
back they already know that a gun a
knife was already presented so of course
they thought their lives were in danger
yeah i think she actually stamped him
with that knife in the shoulder the
shoulder yes yeah i mean this is an easy
defense at this point god fell down now
did i hear about the knife yeah um
it's good to see this like for a lot of
people to see this because i i don't
think people understand that these are
dangerous lines of work in a
crime-ridden city
when we were you know listening to
people on other networks talked about
how they could go out to dinner and
enjoy themselves because everything was
great they're not around when this
happens and i think the mayor
was wise to say what he was saying
because if you start losing businesses
and you can you can already tell that
new york is having a hard time coming
back but you're seeing the tourists
return but if you can't run businesses
uh the then the city's dead and if these
people can't be safe there was a an ugly
event downtown at a like a little
chicken uh nugget place i don't know if
you saw the tape but you should google
it but there was a fight over dipping
sauce and they destroyed the restaurant
this was i guess last night yeah it's
like three in the morning yeah so these
are these are
these are areas where why would you end
up wanting to work in new york why would
you want to open a small business when
you can't protect yourself or if you do
protect yourself you're going to get
arrested you know the police are
maligned so they there's fewer cops out
there so you're left with just a knife
against somebody that might have a gun
and you know god bless this guy
protected himself it wasn't a proactive
act it wasn't vigilante-ism it was
self-defense pure and he should be out
and and um uh you know and maybe the
chilling effect will be on criminals
hopefully arm yourself and now ray's
getting involved and that should
interest maybe create that effect and we
don't want jose to serve any time at all
nope and the five will prevent that
we will we will i guarantee it are you
are you doing a gofundme page
oh they took it down
his gofundme page down why all right
well we know some good lawyers we're
gonna make sure nothing happens to our
friend jose hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else